when I was at Harvard Business School
back in in 1990 there were probably I
know eight people in the nonprofit club
and I think we looked at slightly
askance by the folks because it wasn't
the venture capital club with a finance
club now today on campus the largest
single Club at Harvard Business School
is the social enterprise club so in 20
years or less than that you have had a
shift in something pretty fundamental in
this country around I think young people
wanting to take more responsibility for
those around them seeing the
responsibility slightly more broadly
defined than just motivated self
interest in getting involved so we have
so many more young folks in our colleges
and our grad schools today mentoring our
students volunteering getting involved
in service movements like AmeriCorps and
Vista so I think the pendulum is
certainly swinging to a direction where
many young people are taking more
responsibility for those around them and
realizing that's not at odds with you
know good old motivated self-interest
and free market capitalism and in fact
you know we all remember that in smith
wrote a book all the wealth of nations
and talked about free markets and
capitalism why they were good ultimately
for our society he also wrote another
book it was talking about the theory of
moral essentials and what he said is you
can have a free market and it's going to
work best but at the same time at some
point you have to realize that just
getting more and more and more is
actually not in society's best interest
so even Adam Smith has our free market
economy free market economists would say
there's a concept of being responsible
for others in wrote a book about that
equally I think we don't remember he
actually wrote a few books one of them
talked about moral essentials in the
danger of just seeing in a creative
process without any sense of what's
enough or any sense of distribution that
I have the opportunity now to help
others you know that's equally part of
keeping a very strong in well
function capitalist society in check
certainly many many more grad schools
are offering loan forgiveness or a loan
reduction for those going to the
nonprofit sector and I do think with the
rise of social entrepreneurship the rise
of nonprofits hiring better and better
people growing more quickly that we are
attracting incredible talent into this
sector and the reality is as people are
getting paid more and more so the gap
between the nonprofit and private sector
is shrinking certainly last ten years is
shrinking from when I started back in
two thousand the other way I think about
the pendulum is i'm not a huge proponent
of of handouts so i have not seen with
people who are able-bodied enable minded
the where handouts are producing good
outcomes in a sense of entitlement is a
very destructive sentiment and if you
ever want to play the victim you're not
going to get ahead so when i think about
that pendulum it's there's a lot of
personal accountability that has to be
invested in any nonprofit organization i
think the deserving someone who is able
bodied naval minded i mean there are
needs for charitable acts their needs
for handouts for someone who really
cannot provide for themselves always
slip to a place where they literally
cannot take care of themselves but
that's not a majority i think of what
we're trying to do here especially your
up we believe you've got to combine deep
personal accountability taking charge of
yourself not saying what was me but
saying i want a chance i want an
opportunity I mean America needs to be
an opportunity Society and so the young
adults we serve want an opportunity they
do not want to hand out they want to
hand up and so my belief is that
pendulum in terms of maybe reaching out
and supporting others also has to be
balanced by a healthy dose of personal
accountability for those being helped
and without which I think I don't think
the system will ever work well
you